it's just so utterly preposterous I mean
two of the things they complain about
are literally criticisms of of Trudeau
and like if I can't criticize a standing
prime minister in my own country there
is something seriously wrong one of them
was his chief of staff one of them was a
city councilor
um one of them was the trans issue that
we discussed one of them I criticized to
uh Sports Illustrated for presenting a
very um obese cover model and I said
that as far as I was concerned she
wasn't beautiful and that no amount of
tolerant of authoritarian compassion was
going to convince me otherwise and the
other thing that the other reason that I
think Canadians got mad at that and I
think people in general is that they
think I'm being mean you know and you
should be nice and first of all I'm not
exactly so sure that you should be nice
all the time I think we as a culture
have got ourselves into an awful lot of
trouble by being a little bit too nice
like I'm not so sure I'll give you an
example of that so Nicola sturgeon who
was the former prime minister of
Scotland said any man who says that he's
a woman is a woman you think well that's
pretty nice if the guy wants to be a
woman well we can just go what harm
could it do yeah and then and then the
serial sexual
Slayers in prisons decided that maybe
they were women
because maybe then they could go to
women's prisons and you know if you
don't think that a Serial sexual killer
will manipulate His Image to get access
to women you are a complete blithering
bloody idiot and of course that's
exactly what happened in Scotland and so
sturgeon was called out on her
pathological compassion and that was one
of the things that led to a resignation
it's like
tolerance Beyond a certain level is 100
percent absolutely incontrovertibly a
vice and when tolerance has got to the
point where it's a vice then it's time
to not be so nice when you say Vice what
do you mean
um oh that that's a very good question
you know what it what is advice exactly
well a vice is a pattern of behavior
that if indulged in especially
repeatedly leads to nothing but negative
consequences even by the self-def
definition of the person engaging in the
vice and so look excess alcohol use
tends to be a vice yeah well why okay
how do you diagnose alcoholism as a
pathology well the first thing you do is
you look at amount and frequency let's
say but that's not enough
it has to be a high amount frequently
that causes substantial disruption to
one or more important domains of life so
if you're wondering whether you're
drinking too much you think well is it
compromising your health are your
friends starting to object have you got
in trouble with the law is your wife mad
right exactly exactly so so is the
behavior starting to produce negative
consequences even by your definition or
perhaps even more importantly by your
definition then you'd say well any
behavior that
tends to be quite entertaining in the
short term but let's say not so good
socially or in the long term that's a
vice and we all know that you know
there's lots of things like drinking is
a great example it's an absolute bloody
blast especially if you like alcohol but
you know when I was a kid I used to
drink Fair bit and I quit when I was
about 24 25 maybe a little later than
that and uh you know I was out three or
four times a week having a just a fine
time drinking beer whiskey yeah usually
beer I like beer a lot but I but
whatever was available fundamentally
anything wet yeah yeah and uh
at some point especially as my
professional career developed I realized
that
I realized essentially and this is also
when I started when started my my
permanent relationship with Tammy I
thought you know the only thing I only
time I really do things I regret is when
I'm drinking yeah you know if I'm and
same yeah well that's the thing well
that's a vice man it's like it's not
good for you and it's actually not good
if you're trying to aim up like you
couldn't do what you're doing
now how old are you you diet 27 like you
would have died at 27. most people die
you know and they die from vices
generally you know you're telling me
that last time one of the last times
that we spoke